Because people like me don't matter to people like them.
I'm just the lady that cleans the toilet.
Please, Mrs.
Spector,
I'm not proud to ask you for this,
but my mother needs this.
And when it comes to taking care of people we love,
pride has no place.
Okay, look,
I can't promise anything, but I'll try.
Thank you. I knew you were kind.
Don't tell me you're dating a cleaning woman now.
And what if I was? I'd say congratulations,
but why don't you tell me why she was here?
I ran into her in the bathroom last night.
She was crying. The building isn't paying her what she's owed,
and she asked me to look into it.
You mean she asked you to pick a fight with our landlord,
who I shouldn't have to tell you,
is a mean son of a bitch, and this is a bad idea.
Robert, I'm not an idiot,
and I'm not picking any fights with David Fox.
I'm gonna talk to the man for two minutes.
If he doesn't see it my way,
that's it.
Trust me.
Okay, Harvey.
I trust you.
David Fox. I'm Harvey Spector of something.
Something Spector lit.
Don't tell me us changing our names gonna be an issue again.
No, it's not.
Donna Pulse has thought of that in your new lease.
Well, Donna has a way of getting what she wants.
Speaking of what people want,
why don't you tell me why you're here?
I Need your help. There's a cleaning woman on our floor
who can't afford to pay her mother's medical bills.
Turns out, technically,
she's a facilities manager,
which means she's not eligible to make overtime.
A maid with a manager's title?
It sounds to me like she's being empowered.
You and I both know that title
is just a way to get around paying what she's earned.
I don't know any such thing.
Oh, bullshit.
She's your employee. Wrong.
I contract all my cleaning services out to another company.
A company I don't run. You're gonna tell me that company
is anything more than a piece of paper and a PO box?
Why don't you pay them a visit and find out?
Listen, David,
all I'm asking is do the right thing.
Pay her for her work. You know,
why don't you reach into your own pocket?
Cause that's what you're asking me to do.
And I do this for her. I gotta do for everyone.
And if you don't do it for her,
you will have to do it for everyone.
You better watch what you say to me.
Cause in case you forgot, you're still living under my roof.
And if you don't back off,
I'll take that roof and everything else you have.
Because you just violated half a dozen laws by threatening a tenant.
You wanna take me on, you go for it.
Cause I didn't get where I am by letting people like you push me.
Around last time Donna kicked your ass.
Well, I'm not Donna.
So you pay my client what you owe her.